[Musik]
ein jahr in den usa 1 op das jahr ihres
lebens sollte es werden
wir haben uns mitgenommen ihre familien
in ihr leben
sie sind trotz corona geblieben weit weg
von zuhause haben ihre hoffnungen und
sorgen mit uns geteilt und gezeigt wie
es gerade wirklich ist als ob er in den
vereinigten staaten von amerika
[Musik]
ich bin die kita ich bin 20 jahre alt
und ich lebe auf long island im
bundesstaat new york ungefähr anderthalb
stunden von new york city entfernt und
ich bin seit mittlerweile knapp einem
jahr hier ob er in den usa hier betreut
sie die zehnjährige listen und den zwölf
jahre hier day also das erste was ich
morgens mal mache ist natürlich ins
wohnzimmer zu gehen und dann gehen auch
zu suchen und fragen was sie zum
frühstück haben möchten hier ist jetzt
meine kleine die zehnjährige und ließ
über die uhr vor bergfest sie was willst
du zum frühstück
seit krone muss sich die kita nicht nur
um die versorgung der kinder sondern
auch um deren schulunterricht kümmert ja
morgens wenn die kleines frühstück ist
und werden sie guckt dann gucke ich
meistens auf meinem arbeit handy was sie
für die schule zu tun hat meine kleine
ist in der vierten klasse in ein großes
in der sechsten klasse und ich muss den
kindern viele neue sachen erklären in
der schule ich bin keine gelernte
lehrerin ich weiß natürlich nicht am
besten wie man es den kindern erklärt
klar ich gebe mein bestes ich versuche
jeden tag aufs neue
aber es klappt natürlich auch nicht
immer so perfekt und die kinder
verstehen natürlich auch nicht alles wo
man dem was erklärt ja und wenn sie dann
zb fertig ist ihre geschichten für das
schreiben fertig zu machen und dann muss
ich das immer fotografieren und
verwenden und das wäre ich bin jetzt
einmal sonst tun wir sind fertig mit der
schule und jetzt heißt es kinder
beschäftigung bis heute abend um 18 uhr
und ja anstatt 25 arbeite ich
mittlerweile 45 stunden die woche
neun stunden jeden tag ohne pause von 9
bis 18 uhr
die 20 jährige versucht das beste aus
der situation zu machen
aber es gibt ein großes problem
[Musik]
meine gasteltern sind so das geht
wirklich sehr sehr streng also ich darf
das haus nicht verlassen ich habe das
haus seit märz eigentlich nicht wirklich
verlassen darf auch keine freunde
treffen oder ich darf nicht rausgehen
aus und mit den kindern in den garten zu
spielen also es ist schon sehr sehr
anstrengend 24/7 mit ex-premier
eingesperrt zu sein
weniger freiheiten und viel mehr arbeit
so sieht aktuell das leben von open
source bei nikita wird wie bei vielen
anderen auch im moment die maximale
arbeitszeit von 45 stunden ausgeschöpft
es ist wirklich wirklich anstrengend ob
er ihm momentan zu sein und es ist nicht
einfach wie viele menschen denken also
es ist wirklich wirklich schwer und man
muss halt natürlich das beste aus der
situation machen man muss trotzdem
positiv weiter leben
was einfacher macht die kitas gasteltern
können der familie einen hohen
lebensstandard bieten sie ist anwältin
er unternehmer die familie hat viel
platz und genug ablenkung für die kinder
[Musik]
ja das golf kart fahren mache mir
natürlich auch super gerne denn es ist
eines der sachen den hier bei schönem
wetter am einfachsten machen können
[Musik]
beide wirken mit dem golfcart in dem
großen garten bis zum grundstück der
nachbarn fahren ja papa seid ihr
vorsichtig beim runterfahren
ich liebe dich ich liebe dich auch das
war mein gastvater er wollte wissen ob
es uns gut geht gerne viele menschen auf
viele meiner freunde die
nach hause geflogen sind in diesen
zeiten für mich war das natürlich keine
option denn ich bleibe bis nächstes jahr
juli hier in ihrem ausblick 2010 durch
krone sind nikita und die kinder ständig
zusammen zu hause bleiben heißt auch
mehr zeit miteinander mehr zeit zum
spielen spielen spielen haben die kitas
letzte offizielle aufgabe für heute
abend essen kochen für die kinder häufig
beschäftigt sie sich aber auch danach
noch weiter mit ihnen nach 6 und ich
arbeite trotzdem nochmals mit der kleine
noch draußen war und so was mache ich
als erste mal damit ich mit den kleinen
spielen kann
2018 waren mehr als 3000 deutsche ob er
es in den usa nun sind viele früher
abgereist oder wurden nach hause
geschickt
ängste und befürchtungen habe ich
natürlich dass sie alle leute mit dem j
1 visum nach hause schicken was
natürlich nicht toll wäre denn ich
möchte natürlich auch meine zeit bis
ende juli hier noch gerne nutzen und
natürlich gerne hier bleiben vorerst
darf sie aber in den usa bleiben und
trotz corona so viel spaß wie möglich
haben
[Musik]
hallo ich bin die anna ich wurde ins
gestell einem vorort von new york city
ich bin ein opfer seit juli und ich weiß
auch zwei kinder auf einmal die ärmel
und der preis abgesehen von corona hatte
dieses jahr für anna noch ganz andere
hürden hier ein bisschen ein anderes
erlebnis als jeder andere weil ich
gerade in meiner firmen familien die
erste gastfamilie hatte sich nicht an
die regeln gehalten in der zweiten
fühlte sich die 18 jährige überhaupt
nicht wohl
dann bin ich zu meiner dritten familie
gegangen und da habe ich mich sehr
wohlgefühlt ich habe die kinder gemacht
ich habe mich sehr gut mit den host
einverstanden da war ich auch drei
monate aber genau da war in der korona
virus hatte angefangen und anfang april
hat mir in meiner familie gesagt dass es
sich leider nicht mehr braucht also es
hat mich sehr viel kraft gekostet
nochmal mich zu überwinden und noch mal
in eine viertel familie zu gehen
innerhalb von einem jahr
jetzt geht es ihr richtig gut anna
kümmert sich fast alleine um die kinder
ihr gastvater arbeitet als arzt in new
york city und ist alleinerziehend er
lässt anna und den kindern viele
freiheiten gegen korona musste sie sich
trotzdem einschränken
anfang april wäre nämlich mal freuen
dass deutschland gekommen und wir hätten
einen road trip nach utah gemacht eine
nächste reise wer anfang mai gewesen und
wir werden nach schick habe übers
wochenende geflogen und zur letzter
schritt wäre eben letzte woche gewesen
wir werden an die niagarafälle gefahren
und nach tronto mussten wir leider auch
canceln
doch sie ist nicht allein ich bin eine
freundin tasten gerade die ganzen
fahrstuhl restaurants wo ich von amerika
aber das hilft nicht immer
wenn es manchmal schwer wird oder die
kinder einfach manchmal nicht ganz so
hören dann wünscht man sich eben mal bei
seiner eigenen familie zu sein oder heim
zu fallen ja ich bin froh hilfe
geblieben zu sein ich habe es sehr
vielseitig
anna will so gerne noch einmal nach new
york city ohne corona bevor es in ein
paar wochen für sie zurück nach
deutschland geht
ich bin lena und ich liebe los angeles
genauer in beverly hills
seit fast einem jahr lebt sie hier ihre
zeit als ob er hat sich lena ganz anders
vorgestellt
als wir die nachricht bekommen haben das
nicht dem logbuch das heißt das für mich
dadurch ausgelösten außer seiner sachen
zu machen wie einkaufen oder einfach nur
spazieren zu gehen was uns schon sehr
krass moment vor allem weil wir quasi
direkt vors bringen welches bescheid
bekommen haben und deswegen baic hatte
mit meinem vater besucht dann hat mit
sieben tage miteinander verbracht
nachdem uns passt mir jetzt nichts
gesehen haben
das heißt da aber schon ziemlich
ziemlich traurig trotzdem versucht sie
nach der arbeit so gut es geht die neue
stadt zu erkunden
meist alleine eigentlich sind hier sich
tausende von
touristen
jeden tag allerdings jetzt danke
essen
könnten
da auch die fitness studios geschlossen
sind hat die 20 jährige jetzt wandern in
den hollywood hills für sich entdeckt es
ist auf jeden fall mein workout hier
einmal hoch und wieder nach hause habe
ich meine stunde sport und die ist ihr
besonders wichtig dass man ein bisschen
raus kommt noch mal was geht denn sonst
halt einfach die decke auf den kopf und
auch zu hause hat sie sich an ganz neue
dinge heran gewagt in verschiedene bäume
gerade erst gepflanzt damit wir ein
bisschen was zu tun haben
wir haben zitronen ein zitronenbaum 240
bäume ihre erdbeeren angebaut wir haben
salat angebaut werden guten angebaut
also auf jeden fall erstmal zu tun da
wir nicht wissen wie lang wird der
doktor noch genauer laufen wird aber
lena hat noch zeit sie bleibt bis juli
2021 hat ihre ob er zeit um ein jahr
verlängert damit sie die usa hoffentlich
bald ohne corona entdecken kann
[Musik]
mein name ist sarah ich bin 20 jahre alt
und ich bin aktuell ist hier in amerika
in der nähe von seattle und bin ob er
hier in washington state brach das virus
zu beginn der pandemie besonders stark
aus sarahs ob er leben ist seither ganz
anders ihr tag beginnt sehr früh denn
neben dem versorgen der kinder ist sie
nun quasi auf ihre lehrerin selbst
gerade erst mit der schule fertig
schreibt sie nun die stundenpläne und
korrigiert aufgaben ich fühle mich
[Musik]
anders ich fühle mich auf jeden fall
gestresst das wäre nicht so acht passen
bisher auf kinder auf sondern ich muss
schauen dass sie sicher sind ich muss
schauen dass sie hier jetzt durch corona
nicht irgendetwas anfassen dass sie
jetzt nicht immer verboten aufheben
das sind halt alles so sachen wo ich
halt einfach noch mehr drauf aufpassen
muss und irgendwann habe ich mir sogar
zuerst muss du irgendwie in den griff
bekommen und dann habe ich mir einen
plan gemacht wie ich meine woche so
angehen möchte was ich für mich tun
möchte was ich für mich tun muss deshalb
sind ihr die wöchentlichen treffen mit
ihrer op freundin gerade jetzt besonders
wichtig zusammen essen und einfach über
alles reden
[Musik]
bei den crooner stattfindet sieht das
immer so aus dem wir uns treffen
gerade wir machen bei uns fenster auf
und essen sind uns zur ruhe die man
anderen auch brasilien außer den
gasteltern und deine kinder
es ist einfach eine schwierige situation
und cola hat sich sehr auf meinen job
ausgewirkt
ich lebe seit zehn monaten
ihre gastfamilie hat zwei kinder den
neunjährigen parker und die sechsjährige
lea sophie kommt eigentlich aus
österreich und ist schon seit fast einem
jahr in den usa seit corona ist auch sie
quasi eine lehrerin
[Musik]
ob lesen schreiben rechnen oder aber
biologie projekte für sophie eine gute
übung denn sie möchte lehrerin werden
[Musik]
das homeschooling ist halt jetzt doch
nicht so einfach die kinder die sind
halt nicht mehr so routiniert deswegen
muss man diese szene noch was machen man
muss sich eigentlich entziehen oder auch
mal bei technikproblemen helfen wenn
online unterricht viasuisse stattfinden
soll
aber das wlan nicht will hat sich das
haus ebenso für mich in meiner was jetzt
leider nicht mehr so ist die hohe ist
weg auch wenn ich nicht arbeiten muss
irgendwo im haus arbeitet immer gerade
wer parker ist gerade bei zoom besonders
wichtig auch für sophie die treffen mit
ihren opa freundinnen
auch wenn momentan nur der supermarkt
offen hat
[Musik]
ja
nudeln machen
so viel wollte hier eigentlich so viel
erleben durch corona ist alles geplatzt
kommt mit der vorstellung her dass du
jeden monat jedes monat wohin fliegen
kannst und einfach dass diana des lebens
leben kannst und dann kommt diese
pandemie und du denkst du nur so ja toll
alles andere als einfach
vor allem aber noch so jung ist und sie
ist schnell erwachsen geworden in diesem
jahr aber sie hat auch eine zweite
familie dazu gewonnen
[Musik]
die kita anna lena sarah und sophie sie
alle kamen in die usa wollten reisen so
viel wie möglich von diesem fremden land
sehen die abenteuer ob er hat sie nun
noch mehr herausgefordert als geplant an
ihre grenzen gebracht
wie alle sagen aber sie bereue es nicht
[Musik]